TAMMY, WE'LL STAY WITH THAT
STORY IF ANYTHING ELSE BREAKS,
BUT WE ALSO TO TALK YOU ABOUT
THIS, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS A
NEW STRATEGY TO WIN ELECTIONS
BUT RATHER THAN CONVINCE
EXISTING VOTERS ON THE ISSUES,
THEY'LL JUST CREATE NEW VOTERS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE PROPOSALS TO
GRANT THE RIGHT TO VOTE FELONS
CHILDREN AND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
BRIDGE RUNNING TAMMY AND ME KNOW
IS PROFESSOR JASON NICHOLS.
JASON, WHAT'S THE THINKING
BEHIND THIS?
WHY SHOULD CHILDREN VOTE AND WHY
SHOULD PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
CITIZENS VOTE?
>> WITH CHILDREN, I WOULD AGREE,
I READ ABOUT THE PROPOSAL FOR
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND
PARTICULAR.
THIS IS NOT A POWER GRAB.
WASHINGTON, D.C., HAS NEVER BEEN
IN PLAY FOR REPUBLICANS.
91% WENT FOR HILLARY CLINTON, 4%
WENT FOR DONALD TRUMP, SO THIS
IS NOT A POWER GRAB BY DEMOCRATS
IS NOT A POWER GRAB BY DEMOCRAT
DEMOCRATS.
>> Mark: EVEN ACCEPTING THAT
IT'S A ONE-PARTY STATE,
EXTENDING THE FRANCHISE TO
MINORS, IF YOU'RE SAYING THIS IS
UNNECESSARY, IT'S FINE, BUT IT'S
A RADICAL MOVE NONETHELESS,
ISN'T IT?
>> I WOULD AGREE WITH A 16, BUT
AT 17 WITH PARENTAL CONSENT, YOU
CAN ENLIST IN THE MILITARY, SO I
WOULD SAY PERHAPS WE SHOULD HAVE
SOME SORT OF PROPOSAL WHERE YOU
CAN VOTE AT 17 WITH PARENTAL
CONSENT.
WE WOULD TRUST YOU WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY OF OUR
COUNTRY, THEN WHY CAN'T WE TRUST
YOU TO CAST A VOTE?
>> Mark: SPEAKING OF NATIONAL
SECURITY, WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
BUST INTO THE COUNTRY AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, VOTING IS A
PRIVILEGE OF CITIZENSHIP AND
ALLEGIANCE, OR AM I JUST BEING
MR. SQUARE AS WELL?
>> [LAUGHS]
I WOULD SAY IF YOU'RE REFERRING
PARTICULARLY TO A COUPLE OF
LOCALITIES IN THE STATE OF
MARYLAND, PARTICULARLY
COLLEGE PARK, OBVIOUSLY I HAVE
AN INVESTMENT IN COLLEGE PARK, I
WOULD THINK THAT THE FIRST THING
IS THAT THIS IS A LOCAL MATTER,
IT'S NOT ABOUT VOTING FOR
PRESIDENT OR GOVERNOR OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S ABOUT FIXING POTHOLES, IT'S
ABOUT REMOVING SNOW.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE AN
INVESTMENT, A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
WHETHER THEY ARE DOCUMENTED OR
UNDOCUMENTED, PAY TAXES IN THOSE
AREAS, PAY PROPERTY TAXES, THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT --
>> Mark: TAMMY, GO FOR IT.
>> THE CITY DIDN'T ACTUALLY END
UP PASSING THAT BECAUSE THERE
WAS SUDDENLY A CONCERN THAT
CITIZENS WERE ABLE TO CHIME IN.
YOUR POINT, MARKET, IS KEY.
AT SUCH A TONE AND OUR PRESIDENT
AND ITS THINGS LIKE WHAT L.A.
AND LONDON DO, TELL YOU WHAT THE
LEFT IS UP TO BECAUSE THERE'S NO
PUSHBACK.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FRANCHISE,
IT'S ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING A CITIZEN AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHERE IS THIS ROAD GOING?
OF COURSE, YOU CAN'T HAVE
CHILDREN VOTING.
THEIR BRAIN LITERALLY IS NOT
COMPLETE.
THERE IS A WEB THAT DOESN'T
COMPLETE UNTIL YOU'RE ABOUT 21.
THESE ARE EFFORTS TO AND SOME
CASES CHANGE THE VOTE OR TO
ENFRANCHISE MORE PEOPLE BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T PERSUADE THEM ON THE
ISSUE IS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE HAVING TROUBLE
WITH THAT, BUT IT'S ALSO TO SET
THE PRECEDENT THAT CAN MOVE
THROUGH THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Mark: YOU USE THAT PHRASE
THE IRAQI PEOPLE, TAMMY.
JASON, A VERY FAMOUS OBSERVATION
AFTER THINGS WENT BADLY IN EAST
GERMAN ELECTION, HE SAID IT'S
TIME FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO ELECT
A NEW PEOPLE.
THIS NEW RAINBOW COALITION,
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS,
PEOPLE WITH COLOR,
TRANSGENDER'S, WHATEVER, WASN'T
ENOUGH, SO WE ARE NOW IMPORTING
PEOPLE AND WE ARE NOW EXTENDING
IT DOWN THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL AND
GRADE SCHOOL UNTIL THERE IS A
MAJORITY, IS THAT THE MASTER
PLAN?
>> OF COURSE YOU'RE BEING VERY
HYPERBOLIC THERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WAS
HAPPENING IN COLLEGE PARK.
I THINK TAMMY IS ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT THAT YOU CAN'T CHANGE
THE CHARTER UNLESS YOU HAVE A
6 OUT OF 7 VOTES.
THEY HAVE FOR, SO IT'S A MOOT
DISCUSSION, BUT THERE ARE AREAS
IN MARYLAND WHERE UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE WHO PAY TAXES, WHO ARE
ANTICIPATING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES, ARE ALLOWED TO VOTE
ON A POTHOLE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
NECESSARILY CRAZY ABOUT THAT.
IT'S A SCARE TACTIC THAT SAYS
THIS IS COMING TO NEW YORK CITY.
WE KNOW THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> Mark: WHICH PARAGRAPH OF
THE CONSTITUTION HAS THIS
AMAZING POTHOLE VOTE?
I'M A FOREIGNER, HELP ME GET UP
TO SPEED.
>> POLITICIANS HAVE ONE IDEA
WHAT THEY WANT AND THAT IS TO
BRING IN PEOPLE OR TO ALLOW
PEOPLE HAVE THE VOTE THAT THEY
THINK WILL VOTE FOR THEM.
THEY CONVENIENTLY FORGET ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WE ARE THE
SOVEREIGN.
SPEAKING OF NEW YORK,
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYS HE'S GOING
TO ALLOW 35,000 FELONS WHO ARE
ON PAROLE, WHO HAVE NOT
COMPLETED THEIR SENTENCE BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL ON PAROLE, TO VOTE
AND HE'LL BE ABLE TO DO THAT BY
PARDONING THEM.
THAT ALREADY ALLOWS FELONS TO